b bah I love you too Hello nice to meet
you are you the father can I have your
blessings to ask your daughter for her
number standing there next man is traps
in your daughter in front of you you're
standing there like a
by the grace of Allah subhah wa
taala the response has been overwhelming
to say the very least alhamdulillah
we've had social media personalities and
respected Scholars from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting ideally waiting to hit our
Target of 2 million we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends when I saw this video my it
boiled my blood so much it boil while I
was watching is I I wanted to punch like
I literally wanted to smash my phone I
wanted to I wanted to break into pieces
i w w I was left speechless I done a
video about individuals who are calling
people falely the youth theth this Etc
we have no with the fake fake Macho fake
trying to be a etc yeah okay I call this
Adam guy out please watch that video I
explain in detail what actually a de is
I'm not one of those people who de but
oh boy this man is a de the reaction
we're going to do now there's I think
Bill across the Muslim nations and
Scholars this man is a festar full like
fullblown five star grade you watch this
video where his daughter who's dressed
up inappropriately anyways yes to a
certain degree and she's getting chirs
by some next man and they are casually
this man is is there standing while his
daughter is getting chirped saying oh
how do you say I love you we're going to
watch it now just watch it man just just
watch it please just rip don't rip your
hair out man just let's watch it for our
in and I'm going to tag the other video
of what an actual D is and for those who
are misusing this in but let's watch
this video in get there where' you get
there my dress the beauty it's amazing
what's your
name EST EST where you from that's a
unique name Middle Eastern what part
Syrian so you speak Syrian yeah Arabic
Arabic yes how do they say love you in
Arabic I want to know how to say that
when
day B I love you too Hello nice to meet
you are you the father Yes nice to meet
you can I have your blessings to ask
your daughter for her number maybe one
day we could go out on a date no okay
well much respect I'll always respect
that I love you guys too you guys take
care have a good
[Music]
one coming
you want to give me your
number yeah you can add me I'll give you
my in Instagram
safe you play Zombies Plants versus
Zombies April yes what about bro Stars
no do you okay uh yeah I play bro Stars
here you go maybe we can be friends and
hopefully we could go out someday
there's a lot to explore here are you
guys tourists San die oh it's a better
place in La it's like LA but without all
the traffic traffic the homeless yeah
Mexican we live in the LA area so we are
come here so guys you saw that for
yourself oh boy oh boy oh my gosh can
you imagine you are standing there next
man is TRS in your daughter moving to
your da in front of you you're standing
there like a you are a full-blown
de you have no protective jealousy of
your daughter I don't care bro let me
tell you something I'm not someone who
uses the word the forever like I don't
think I've ever live with anyone in my
life this man is a the bro and then
afterwards the man's like yeah you know
how do you say I love you or this that
Etc you know and then they're
translating it for him Etc and he's CHS
in messing around bro I would have spark
him in his face bro the moment if I saw
him near my daughter bro bro that trying
to speak bro I would flip in bro like
seriously bro come on like are you
taking the Mi and then he walks
off she comes back he's there and this
girl of hers what kind of a daughter
rebellious daughter this one girl is w I
I don't know what to say I don't know if
she's practicing not I don't know what
to say I blame her father mother than
her she comes back in front of her dad
her dad's there with the child standing
like a statue and she's given her
details to some next man that was Ching
her a cfir and he's there just casually
watching I would rather die bro I would
rather die than know that I was standing
there while some next man was actually
literally planning and plotting to take
my daughter's number and what do you
think is going to happen do you think
he's going to say yeah I want to marry
you do you what do you think going what
do you think he trying to do and he's
there just casually yeahi yeah no
problem yeah yeah CH Mah aldah now she
the way she's dressed up Etc it can be
that a man has given n to his daughter
his wife his whoever it is that you
should not dress up like that if she
doesn't listen you canot necessar say
he's a d because he's doing his bit but
obviously he can come we can come and
say you know but you should not stay
married to a woman like that we can kind
of give that but the fact that the woman
his her mother had some kind of G level
where she was trying to say some stuff
like you know be careful to him or
something like that in Arabic I didn't
know but he's there standing while his
daughter is getting CHS you make me sick
Bro W you make me sick you make me sick
they we have I have I was like I had
more G over this situation than this man
himself I just wanted to share that with
you guys please watch the video where I
discuss what is an actual and those who
misuse it inshallah that's what I want
to say may Allah subh bless and protect
you guys till next time
and if this made you as sick as I did
please share this with someone that
might benefit from it to next time